[Music]
herd immunity could be our best
chance of getting back to enjoying
ourselves together
if enough people have the antibodies for
covered 19
the entire population can be protected
but is that
an impossible dream can global herd
immunity
ever be achieved without it will the
pandemic
ever be truly over as vaccinations
ramp up these are the questions being
asked
around the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm rob watts in berlin welcome to dw's
covered 19
special now we've been hearing the term
herd immunity throughout the pandemic
in the early days when some were
suggesting we should let infections run
riot to achieve it as
fast as possible and nowadays with
vaccinations making it possible to boost
the population's protection
in a controlled and rather safer way
but how does herd immunity actually work
well let's have a look what is
herd immunity if many in a herd are
immune to a disease the pathogen cannot
spread further
that's when herd immunity is achieved
[Music]
why is herd immunity important
we can use it to protect the weak babies
for example
they're too young to be vaccinated
against some diseases
for people with chronic diseases as well
because they can't tolerate vaccinations
those with a weak immune system such as
after chemotherapy also benefit
because herd immunity reduces the risk
of getting infected
how many have to be immune
[Music]
that varies depending on the disease the
important factor is the reproduction
rate of a pathogen
it indicates the number of people on
average that one infected person will
pass on a virus to
the higher the number the more
infectious it is for measles
the basic reproduction rate is 15. for
covet 19
it's about three how is herd immunity
calculated
very simply with this formula where h is
equal to one
minus one divided by r zero for the
coronavirus that means that the herd
immunity h
is one minus one divided by three which
is two-thirds
that means two-thirds of the population
must be immune to have herd immunity
in germany that would be over 50 million
people
what conditions must be met the
prerequisite for herd immunity is that
the antibodies we produce in an
infection
need to protect us in the long term with
covet 19
it's not yet clear how long someone who
has survived the disease will be immune
what is certain is that people who have
been infected are protected for at least
several weeks
[Music]
well let's speak to edwin michael he's
an epidemiologist
at the university of south florida's
college of public health thanks for
joining us on the carving 19 special
you've been modeling timelines for herd
immunity so i suppose the place to start
is
is it possible to achieve it and if so
when
and if you look at the models which are
uh um you know
predictions of you know the fraction of
people that we need to immunize
to get heard immunity that is a function
of
you know the transmission rate it is a
function of
the efficacy of the vaccines you know so
those two
will vary between places and if you look
at
how people are mixing if you look at you
know the
the normal models that we use which is
the worst case
scenario if you assume people are mixing
randomly
then you can work out what fraction of
people might need to be immunized to get
hurt immediately
and that works out for um for cobit
between 80 to 95
uh or 80 to 80 to 90 of the people need
to be vaccinated to get
herd immunity now to answer your
question we are now
about 50 50 just above 50 percent
of people are immune here in the u.s you
know um
it's a combination of acquired immunity
as well as
vaccine india's immunity so that means
we have to go
you know another 30 percent of the
people need to get immunized
in order to achieve her divinity can we
achieve her diminity
well that's going to depend on people
taking up the vaccines and that take-up
is slowing
and also whether there's a substantive
people
who are going to resist taking the
vaccine
no we're just talking about the united
states here though aren't we
we're just talking about the united
states can we
you know heard of immunity seems like a
tangible concept there although
there are a lot of people who still need
to be persuaded to get the vaccine to
get there
but what about for the entire world can
i i mean is it realistic to say that we
can get there for the entire world
yeah i mean if you look at um you know
if you look at vaccination rates
you know and that's a huge difference
right uh
between countries uh the top countries
would be
israel as we know uh united arab
emirates
you know and among the major countries
is the uk
and the united states you know and
they are reaching 50 above already
and if you look at europe the european
countries in general the other european
the eu countries
is between 20 to 30 percent you know and
so they are a long way to go
so you know so the countries that have
started
vaccinating uh very early have reached
very high levels of
immunity already the rest of the country
africa is going to be a concern
not much is known and we have seen what
is happening in india
with just below 10 percent of the
population
being immunized you know and the danger
with that is if you release social
measures you're going to get
the kinds of spikes or the waves that
you're seeing in india which is
devastating
you know that country so you're right
there's a long long way to go um
before globally we're going to achieve
uh herd immunity
and so i think when we talk about that
we're talking about herd immunity to
specific strains of coronavirus or are
we talking about you know
to to to every possible incarnation of
this novel coronavirus
that's a really good question you know
and that is going to depend on the kinds
of immune responses which have been
induced by the vaccines right and if you
look at a vaccine yes the mrna vaccine
they are
you know the immune response um you know
is induced to the spike protein
yes but you know that is a whole range
of immune response to the
spike protein is not just one particular
response to this spike protein so if you
get another strain
unless that strain uh you know the
mutation in the strain is
completely normal and completely you
know elsewhere from the spike protein
you know that is going to reduce the
efficacy of the vaccines
you know it is the efficacy rates which
is going to govern
the fraction of people that we need to
immunize
now evolutionarily um you know getting
to
that kind of an a brand new strain
you know it's a long shot you know for
the virus as well
so we could also right now ultimately we
could be looking at needing
multiple herd immunities right it's not
actually that we're aiming to end this
pandemic with
herd immunity it's that we need heard
immunities
to the various different variants
yeah i mean yes um because the
efficacies will vary you know
between strains you know the vaccine
efficacies and that is going to
dictate you know the amount of people
that you're going to
uh need to vaccinate but in general you
know
with uh even if a ten percent um you
know difference in
the efficacy rates in all the vaccines
against the difference
and strains we're still looking at that
you know
that window of you know eighty to ninety
percent
right or people need to be vaccinated
as you rightly put it you know globally
uh if you want to see the end of this
pandemic as a global phenomenon
well we'll get there one day hopefully
edwin michael from the university of
south florida's
college of public health thanks for
joining us
thank you thank you now you may be one
of the lucky ones who's already been
vaccinated
against kovid19 if so you may have also
asked yourself today's question for our
science correspondent derek williams
how long will the vaccines offer
protection
we don't know yet and even when we do
know more
there won't be a single answer to this
question since
about a dozen different vaccines
are currently in use around the world
and since they're made by
different manufacturers and are based on
a range of different platforms
they almost certainly won't all protect
people for the same periods of time
on average what we can say is that the
makers of some of the first vaccines to
enter use
widely last december are now reporting
back
that levels of antibodies have generally
remained quite high in recipients
which is an indicator that those people
are still
well protected six months after getting
their shots
those results have researchers hopeful
that
immune response at least that induced
by those vaccines will last at least a
year
and and possibly a lot longer but
developers aren't leaving it to chance
most have already started
modifying and testing the next
generation of vaccines some of which
specifically target um variants of
concern
um trials involving a third booster shot
with them
are ongoing and and don't forget
though there's no sign yet that
vaccine-induced protection is
is beginning to wane even if it does
that won't happen overnight and even if
immunity does
start to drop faster than predicted
healthcare authorities would notice it
early
and and a lot of the experts i've read
seem to be pretty confident that we'll
be able to respond quickly
derek williams there if you've got a
question for derek you can submit one
through our youtube channel we're
putting as many to them and many of them
to him as we possibly can
and before we go things are starting to
look a little bit more
like normal in the spanish capital
madrid where the first
bull fight has been held since the
pandemic began
seating was restricted and spectators
wore face masks as they watched matadors
take on seven bulls in a charity event
to raise money for
out of work bull fighters uh
temperatures were taken at the door
and another tradition was also back
animal rights protesters
outside raising their objections while
remaining
socially distant
and that's all from me in this covered
19 special if you do want more
check out our website until next time
goodbye
[Music]
you